but uh damn
this has got to be one of the best games
i've ever played i mean that
you're actually quitting like officially
i mean like i might come back in a
couple weeks to check out the new update
or something but i'm playing apex and
i'm going to upload apex if they don't
like it they can suck it i go to drink
my smoothie and think about apex
i go take a shower thinking about apex
everyone went to fortnight your boy took
over on fortnite early with that
controller gang and dominated then we
went to warzone we won two big
tournaments back to back to back and
made some serious noise in the warzone
vr and now we're over here on apex
from now on i'm uploading whatever the
hell i'm playing that's it i don't care
anymore
okay
all right give me one give me a crack
give me crack right give me five
give me spread hey one more one more one
more left
let's go baby
what's up what's up what's up how many i
gotta put in the dirt if i hit this you
guys
you hear me
i'm your daddy
[Music]
fortnite spawned an entire generation of
big name streamers superstars more
famous than the gaming world had ever
seen when is the last time all of us
played
it's been a w it's been a while dude
gangs all here dude some of these stars
have become so synonymous with the game
that it's impossible to picture one
without thinking of the other that said
a few of fortnite's biggest stars have
found a way to split off from the
franchise they got their start in but
none were able to make the transition
quite as smoothly as nicholas nick
merk's culture
and what's more leaving fortnight for a
call of duty warzone was neither the
first nor the last time that nick merks
switched games good afternoon and
welcome back to the channel i'm sorry
for the late upload i was up all night
last night playing uh
apex
before nick murx became known as one of
the biggest streamers on the planet and
the one true controller god of battle
royales he was actually a gears of war
competitor
who's taking it home
he also played a little bit of
professional halo around the same time
that future fellow fortnighter ninja was
doing the same i was beating ass every
night man i mean no matter what no
matter what game halo cod gears of war
which is beating ass so i knew i was
good
but i had no idea would turn into this
you know what i mean piggybacking on his
gears of war fame to build a following
in 2010 nick marks joined twitch's
precursor justin tv and in 2011 youtube
throughout the years he streamed games
like call of duty black ops 3 cs go
outlast destiny 2 and even monopoly
interspersed with health and fitness
segments even early on nick was never
afraid to try something different even
if that meant shoulder pressing on
camera in an era where streaming was
just about gaming but it wasn't until
the 2017 release of fortnite that nick
mercs found the game that would catapult
him into the streaming stratosphere
[Music]
oh
as always in fortnight nick balanced the
casual with the competitive he joked
grinded screamed and fragged out in a
scene that allowed you to be an
entertainer and a competitor all at once
and in fortnight's early days he set
several world records including one for
the most squad kills
twice
as his streaming channels generated more
and more views nick mercs was invited to
join hundred thieves an org owned by
fellow cod aficionado and friend
nadeshot unfortunately the promising
arrangement quickly soured due to
internal conflicts what's up bro you
with the honcho ceo what's up bro is
some ceo [ __ ]
watch watch your hand watch your hand
cause
cause the dog bites back homie in may of
2019 nick merk's and hundred thieves
parted ways for good and hard as it is
for me to admit this
i just don't have the knowledge and the
i don't have
i can't sit down at those tables and
talk that business with those guys i
just didn't take those classes i didn't
go to college to do and work and say a
lot of the things that those guys say so
that's
you know when the hunter thieves thing
started i didn't have anybody to
represent me or lead me or guide me
all i had was my buddy nadeshot and he
let that [ __ ] spin out of control but
the morning period after the hundred
thieves split didn't last long it was
that same month that nick merks became
part of faze clan the notoriously
scrappy org that seemed better suited to
his game bro persona but not only that i
get to start with a you know a new and
improved uh you know team in gaming you
know a colossal and that's something
that i'm stoked for to be honest with
you and the org swap wasn't the only big
change for nick merks that year on july
8th he proposed to longtime girlfriend
emu mita bonita on stream she goes oh my
god honey we gotta get married here i go
why she goes they have chickens i'm like
i don't even i don't
i don't say nothing the pair officially
tied the knot on october 10th 2020 but
not all of nick murx's long-term
commitments were meant to last earlier
that year right around the time the
world shut down due to a global pandemic
he became enraptured with a new game
call of duty war zone and fortnite fell
by the wayside it's such a such a
well-made br man i feel really bad for
people that just can't
break out and enjoy it you know what i
mean i mean hey if you're addicted to
fortnite and you're rocking it's your
thing no harm no foul but uh damn
this has got to be one of the best
games i've ever played i mean that
just in terms of
balance flow pace the weapons
the fights
the skill gaps it's incredible
[Music]
making a full-time jump to an entirely
new game can make or break streamers but
nick murx was not about to dance to the
beat of anyone else's drum but his own
warzone became his new obsession and he
was gonna follow his heart whether
anyone liked it or not
luckily for nick merks his fans didn't
just like the move they loved it on top
of this
is it nice no this is like the fourth
super man i've killed i got sniped i
have a guy down on me though
you haven't done more than 2 thousand
damage all [ __ ] day right right right
right you haven't done more than two
thousand damage comics peanut calories
shouldn't you be eating maybe the more
food you eat the better you would get
right
became one of the first big fortnight
creators to embrace warzone and make it
his go-to game on stream and it was
important to him that his community felt
at home in cod nick murx established and
ran a tournament series the mfam
gauntlet and made sure the tournament's
namesake mfam as his subscribers are
known felt included and welcome in this
new space
don't tell me
where on me yeah in the back weak weak
no shield in the hood
oh baby
get the [ __ ] out of my lobby nick merks
was someone who never needed anyone's
approval to do his own thing he was as
intensely passionate about war as he was
about everything else that mattered to
him whether it was clicking heads in
game or his community's welfare
you know i love my family uh
[Music]
love my family yeah
for nick mercs it was always the
combination of genuine personality and
undeniable talent that has been his
signature feature not what game was on
the screen and that energy continued to
draw in more people who wanted to see
him do what he did best the energy the
fam the frags and the passion became an
unstoppable train barreling towards the
top of twitch
hey are you if you were to land there
with me originally we would have been
fine
just laying there with me recognition of
nick murx's efforts and big sponsorships
followed instead of losing viewers as
could be expected after such a radical
change his slice of the streaming pie
grew even bigger but after a sizzling
year and a half with warzone nick murx
found himself on the receiving end of
massive cod burnout i have no desire
whatsoever to play warzone zero i mean
like goosey
i i'd rather play
in pokemon
i'm serious man he tried to shake things
up a bit by dabbling in fortnite and
ramping up his fitness content but like
any bonafide gamer he was missing the
fire that a truly outstanding fps could
light under his well-practiced behind
and it wasn't just that warzone was
getting stale there was also a massive
unaddressed cheating problem to contend
with you can't even get up a ladder but
you have a hundred kd right nice [ __ ]
automated system dog [ __ ] you should
feel bad about yourself actually i'd say
get your money back but it's a free game
that accounts getting banned go make
another one guys it's getting crazy out
there all right people have programs
that are designed to see everybody in
your lobby stream snipers have tools
they've never had before to stream snipe
us to hack on us it's getting ridiculous
the boys and i are low-key really fed up
man on top of all that now that nick
merks has had a taste of the freedom of
choice if a new game was going to call
out to him he was going to answer that
call which is exactly what he did once
he discovered apex legends then we went
to fortnite your boy took over on
fortnite early with that controller gang
and dominated then we went to war zone
we won two big tournaments back to back
to back and made some serious noise in
the war zone br and now we're over here
on apex i don't know what the plan is
but i'm invested
another team
behind you behind you
back down another
and i'm done
baby jay
here's your new booby wig yo come to me
i'm the best spot really good fight do
you have any names for this i'm with you
okay okay
got so into apex that he reached master
rank after less than two weeks of
playing what do you know huh
landing at the same spot
inserting the same
with
dick
same two lads they've been playing the
same week and a half diving head first
into apex helped nick marks gain a new
appreciation for the particular playing
style he was known for using a
controller instead of a mouse and
keyboard and draw apt comparisons
between the games that helped shape his
career thus far he's become the battle
royale tastemaker the physical demand it
might sound corny but the physical
demand on your hands
from playing apex to warzone
is crazy apex there's there's more going
on man there's just more going on you
gotta do more with your hands i'm
telling you that war zone okay now it
might be because i put a lot of time in
but listen to me right now
there's no game like fortnite nothing
nothing
when you see a good really good
controller player on fortnite i need you
to know the stuff they're doing is
insane it's [ __ ]
insane it's not
even comparable to apex or warzone today
nick merks is one of the most prolific
streamer personalities on the planet
he's been on the cover of sports
illustrated he has millions of followers
across his various channels tens of
thousands of which tune in each time he
goes live as the elite proxy for the
everyman gamer nick marks has managed to
gain the love of his followers without
sacrificing who he was in the process or
giving up his right to choose what to do
on stream and then at this point in the
house if you have somehow managed to
take five shits and you need to take a
sixth
you can do it in here
nick marks has transcended the games he
plays his viewers are no longer here for
the titles they're here for nick mercs
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]